في اوكرانيا شريط النار قد يعبر عما يحدث
على الجبهه المشتعله الممتده على طول
المنطقه الواقعه من جنوب مقاطعه دونيتسك
باتجاه جنوب مقاطعه
وامتدادا الى مقاطعه خرسون وحديث اوكراني
عن اكثر من اربعين غاره جويه روسيه وستين
هجوما صاروخيا في يوم واحد المتحدث باسم
الاداره العسكريه في اوديسا اشار الى تعرض
مستودع للذخيره في منطقه ريكوبي جنوبيه
خرسون للاستهداف ما ادى الى تفجيره
بالكامل عمده الاوكرانيه لم يتاخر عن
القول ان المستودع تستخدمه القوات الروسيه
مركزا لتجميع المعدات وتخزين الوقود
وبتزامن مع قصف متبادل في خرسون كثافه
للقصف الروسي في منطقه زابولوجيا استهدفت
مواقع متقدمه بعد انحسار مياه سبيكه وتحرك
القوات الروسيه بضعه كيلومترات وفق مراسل
الجزيره المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه قال ان القوات الرو هجمات لثلاث
كتائب تكتيكيه اوكرانيه عند محور
زابولوجيا ودمرت مستودعه ذخيره اوكرانيا
في المقاطعه الجنوبيه منطقه تابريا مسرح
مواجهه اخرى جنوبيه
يتحدث الاوكرانيون عن تنفيذ اكثر من 1800
ضربه صاروخيه ومدفعيه خلال يوم واحد
وتدمير عشرات الاليات الروسيه لكنها تبقى
روايه من طرف واحد فالقوه الروسيه بدورها
اعلنت صده ثمن هجمات اوكرانيه عبر محور
على جبهه بخموت قال نائب وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ان القوات الاوكرانيه هجمت
الضواحي الشماليه والجنوبيه لبخموت بينما
تحدث الروسو عن صد هجمات بريه اوكرانيه
محدوده على خط مدينه افديف كادونيات
مقاطعه كورسك الروسي على الحدود باتت
مهدده وفق سلطات المقاطعه التي وضعت كل
السيناريوهات لاجلاء سكان القرى والبلدات
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا بسبب وجود من وصفتهم
بمجموعه تخريب اوكرانيه على الحدود ودوما
على الحدود افاد حاكم مقاطعه
بقصف القوات الاوكرانيه لها باكثر من 120
قذيفه ومسيره تحمل عبوات ناسفه العين ايضا
على تحركات لاسطول البحر الاسود الروسي
الذي يعيد انتشاره بشكل مستمر في شبه
جزيره القرم وفق المتحدث باسم القوات
البحريه الاوكرانيه هي تطورات لافته
التهابت معها ساحه القتال بينما اكدت
تقرير لوزاره الدفاع البريطانيه تكبد
الطرفي القتال خسائر كبيره في الجنود
لكنها وفق التقرير الاعلى بالنسبه للجنود
الروس منذ احتدام معركه بخموت في مارس
الماضي